تجمع في العاصمه البلجيكيه بروكسل مئات
المزارعين القادمين من عده دول اوروبيه
للاحتجاج على ضغوط الاسعار والضرائب
واللوائح الخضراء واشعل المحتجون الذين
دخلوا بجرارات الى المكان النيران للتعبير
عن سخطهم بالتزامن مع عقد قاده دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي قمه استثنائيه تركز بشكل
خاص حول المساعدات الاقتصاديه والعسكريه
لاوكرانيا وسيكون على القاده المجتمع في
بروكسل اليوم اقناع المزارعين بامكانيه
التوصل الى اتفاق بما يخص مطالبهم وكانت
المفوضيه الاوروبيه قدمت يوم امس تنازلات
بشان امرين يثيران استياء المزارعين فقد
اقترحت بالنسبه للعام الجاري منحى اعفاء
جزئي من اراحه الاراضي الالزاميه التي
تفرضها السياسه الزراعيه المشتركه وبحث
اليه للحد من الواردات الاكرانيه وخاصه
الدواجن
تبعنا صور مباشره طبعا لما يحصل في
بروكسال وينضم الينا عبد الله الشامي عبد
الله هل امام القاضه الاوروبيين حلول
مقنعه
لهؤلاء هذه المساله جلال ليست حديثه وانما
كل عام تقريبا تثار نفس التساؤلات من قبل
هؤلاء المزارعين الذين كما قلت في الخبر
ينضم اليهم مزارعون من دول اخرى هناك
احتجاج بشكل كبير بدا يتصاعد من هؤلاء
المزارعين بسبب الدعم المالي الذي تقدمه
او الذي تقدمه بروكسل اي الاتحاد الاوروبي
للمزارعين القادمين من اوكرانيا بعد بدايه
الحرب كانت هناك يعني استفهامات لاي درجه
يمكن ان يقدم الاتحاد هذا الدعم المالي
لانه يؤث ثر بالتبعيه على محاصيلهم
ومنتجاتهم الزراعيه الحديث الان هو ايضا
حول الطرق التي يمكن ربما بها تهدئه غضب
هؤلاء تحدث رئيس الوزراء البلجيكي هذا
الصباح عما قال انه مناقشات مكثفه ستجري
اليوم رغم ان هذا البند ليس على اجنده
القمه الاستثنائيه المنعقده اليوم حول
السبل التي يمكن بها اعفاء هؤلاء
المزارعين من الضرائب الباهظه وكذلك ايضا
ما له علاقه باللوائح الخضراء هناك
احتجاجات من هؤلاء المزارعين من ان
القوانين التي يريد الاتحاد الاوروبي
تطبيقها من حيث نوعيه الاسمده المستخدمه
وكذلك ايضا نوعيه ربما القرارات التي يجب
تطبيقها من حيث اراحه الاراضي اي وجود
فترات بين كل عمليه زراع واخرى لا تعطيهم
الدخل الكافي او العوائد المنتظره هناك
ايضا احتجاج على الاتفاقيه اتفاقيه
المركسور الاتفاقيه بين الاتحاد الاوروبي
وكذلك دول امريكا اللاتينيه التي تسمح
بدخول محاصيل من هذه المناطق الرئيس
الفرنسي كان قد عبر عن رفض بلاده لهذه
الاتفاقيه لان المزارعين الفرنسيين هم جزء
كبير من هذه التظاهرات القائمه هنا اليوم
هؤلاء المزارعون كما نرى في هذا البث
المباشر حاولوا الوصول الى ميدان شومان
حيث يجتمع القاده اليوم لكنهم وصلوا الى
ناحيه البرلمان الاوروبي حيث جرت مناوشات
وصدامات على مستوى متوسط بينهم وبين
الشرطه وكانت هناك نوع من
يعني الاضرار في المباني المحيطه
بالبرلمان حتى الان لا يبدو ان هناك ربما
نيه لهؤلاء المزارعين الذين ايضا يتواجدون
على العديد من الطرق السريعه هنا في
بلجيكا لربما تهدئه ما يجري من مظاهرات
واحتجاجات قالوا انهم سيستمرون اذا لزم
الامر في البقاء في هذه الاماكن الى اجل
غير المسمى لحين سحب المفاوضيه الاوروبيه
كامل التفاصيل التي لها علاقه بما يسمى تم
باللوائح الخضراء وكذلك العمل على تعويضهم
عن امرين كما قلنا هم ما تم تقديمه
للمزارعين الاوكرانيين وفي ناحيه اخرى
ايضا ما يتم العمل عليه مع البلاد التي
يتم استيراد محاصيل منها من امريكا
اللاتينيه شكرا لك عبد الله الشامي في
بروكسل اذا لازلنا نتابع هذه الصور من
بروكسل لاشعال محتجين دخلوا بجرارات الى
هذه الساحه
واضرم النيران للتعبير عن سخطهم بالتزامن
مع عقد قاده دول الاتحاد الاوروبي قمه
استثنائيه تركز بشكل خاص حول المساعدات
الاقتصاديه والعسكريه لاوكرانيا هذا
التجمع اذا في العاصمه البلجيكيه بروكسل
لمئات المزارعين القادمين ليس فقط من
بلجيكا وانما من عده دول اوروبيه